i was gonna ask if you had the
opportunity would you go
yeah i'm joking about the cockroach
thing and i would definitely go
i love challenges i love i love things
i love doing things where the
possibility of death
is is uh not insignificant
because it makes me appreciate it more
meditating on death makes me appreciate
life
and uh when the meditation on death is
forced on you because of how difficult
the task is
i enjoy those kinds of things most
people don't it seems like
but i love the idea of difficult
journeys
um for no purpose whatsoever except
exploration going into the unknown
seeing what the limits of the human mind
and the human body are
it's like what the hell else is this
whole journey that we're on for
i i uh but it could be because i grew up
in the soviet union there's a kind of
love for space like
the the space race the cold war created
i don't know if still
it permeates american culture as much
but especially with the dad as a
scientist
i think i've i've loved the idea of
humans striving
out towards the stars always like from
the engineering perspective
has been really exciting i don't know if
people love that as much in america
anymore i think
elon is bringing that back a little bit
that excitement about rockets and not
going out there but uh so that's that's
hopeful but for me i always loved that
idea
you